lernen im schlaf sich einfach ins bett
legen und am nächsten morgen die
französische vokabeln in und auswendig
zu kennen oder aber die präsentation
für das büro einfache formen zu
können ohne es einmal so zu haben
die theorie vom lernen im schlaf gibt es
schon länger doch jetzt hat ein
forscherteam konkrete hinweise darauf
gefunden unter welchen umständen das
tatsächlich funktionieren kann
ob das jetzt das ende der nervigen
paukerei bedeutet ob wir demnächst
schlafend eine neue fremdsprache lernen
können und wie wir durch schlaf
leistungsfähiger werden können erfahrt
ihr jetzt den krieg von science fiction
herzlich willkommen
also erstmal ganz sicher ist schlafen
macht schlau
das zeigen viele verschiedene studien
von schlaf forscherinnen und forscher
aus der ganzen welt die fachwelt ist
sich einig wir menschen und auch die
meisten an und lebewesen brauchen schlaf
damit unser gehirn das erlebte in wissen
umwandeln kann das zeigt zum beispiel
ein experiment eines forscherteams aus
tübingen mit 16 monate alten baby
die kinder chancen durch bilder von
fantasie objekten an und wirken
gleichzeitig nahmen die den
verschiedenen objekten zugeordnet waren
die eine gruppe der kinder dürfte dann
schlafen die anderen kinder spielen
danach wurden den babys die bild
wortpaare wieder gezeigt und ihre
gehirnaktivitäten in einem
elektroenzephalogramm kurz eeg gemessen
die kinder die wache blieb waren hatten
die namen der einzelnen objekte
vergessen
ganz im gegensatz zu den babys die
geschlafen hatten diese erinnerten sich
an die zuordnung und konnten neue
objekte sogar die namen von objekten mit
ähnlichem aussehen zu ordnen beide
fähigkeiten hatten wie vor ihrer
schlafpause noch nicht gehabt ein
experiment das eindrucksvoll belegt wie
wichtig schlaf ist neue informationen
prägen sich langfristig ins gedächtnis
wie gelangen also vom arbeitsspeicher in
unserer langzeitgedächtnis außerdem
werden erinnerungen abgespeichert womit
die grundlagen für lernprozesse gelegt
werden und nicht nur das auch motorische
fähigkeiten die wir neu erlernt haben
festigen sich während des schlafs
molekularbiologisch gesehen nutzt unser
gehirn unsere schlafphasen um molekulare
abfallstoffe aus den zellen zu
transportieren allerdings passiert das
lernen im schlaf nur unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen sowohl unser
schlafverhalten als auch die qualität
unseres schlafen
die sind ausschlaggebend dafür wie
effizient unser gehirn diese zeit nutzen
kann wer unausgeschlafen ist ist er
unkonzentriert und konnte sich in tests
beispielsweise weniger an seine eigenen
beobachtung als augenzeuge erinnern als
probanden die ausgeschlafen machen das
ist wirklich irre
das macht man wieder deutlich wozu der
menschliche körper in der lage ist im
schlaf lernen wir quasi wie von selbst
ohne dass wir groß etwas dafür tun
müssen wie traumhaft wäre es also wenn
wir unsere gedächtnisleistungen nachts
gezielt fördern könnten
eine idee die forscher sind weltweit
verfolgen und in verschiedenen
experimenten genauer untersuchen und
auch unternehmen haben diesbezüglich
schon ihre große chance gewittert
im netz gibt es unzählige angebote an
lernen im schlaf kurven
wir versprechen das was eine tonband
stimmungs nachts mit beruhigender stimme
ins ohr flüstert sollen morgens direkt
abrufbar sein
egal ob vokabeln gewichte oder
mathematische formeln doch klar
forscherinnen und forscher wesentlich da
uneinig ob das funktionieren kann
bezweifelt wird nicht dass wir unsere
erinnerungen und erlebnisse im
gedächtnis festigen doch die große und
äußerst spannende frage lautet können
wir während des schlafes auch komplett
neue inhalte lernen studien liefern dazu
bislang widersprüchliche ergebnisse und
warum das so ist
darauf gibt es jetzt ein aktuelles
experiment aus frankreich darauf gibt
das experiment neue hinweise
die schlaf forscherinnen und forscher
aus paris haben nämlich indizien dafür
gefunden dass die lernfähigkeit unseres
gehirns von der jeweiligen schlafphase
abhängig ist das wäre die erklärung
vielleicht genau der weg wie wir
wirklich im schlaf lernen könnten
experiment war folgendermaßen aufgebaut
20 probanden bekamen während des
schlafes eine bestimmte tonfolge
vorgespielt nach dem aufwachen sollten
sie dann diese tonfolgen in einem
rauschen identifizieren um möglichst
schnell wieder erkennen aus vorherigen
studien weiß man dass dies den
testpersonen gut gelingt wenn sie die
entsprechenden konsequenzen vorher
mehrmals bei wachem zustand gehört und
somit verinnerlicht hatten
doch was würde das vorspielen im schlaf
bewirken das ergebnis tatsächlich
erkannten die teilnehmer und
teilnehmerinnen die töne
nach dieser lerneinheit im schlaf
deutlich besser als bei kontrollen
versuchen bei denen ihr gehirn vorher
nicht mittun folgen konfrontiert wurde
jedoch mit einer gravierenden
einschränkungen beim hören der töne
in der tiefschlafphase stellte sich kein
lernerfolg rein nur während der
traumschlaf phase oder im leicht schlaf
die beschallung während der
tiefschlafphase für diese radtour
gegenteil die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer schnitten schlechter ab
das fazit des forscherteams ist
eindeutig nicht in jeder schlafphase ist
lernen möglich je nach schlafphase kann
bildung neuer erinnerungen gefördert
oder auch eben unterdrückt
werden auch wenn die teilnehmerzahl an
diesem experiment er klein war ist dies
eine erkenntnis auf die weitere
forschung in diesem bereich aufbauen
kann nun hängt es an den
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die mechanismen dahinter zu verstehen
eine absolut spannende frage ist auch ob
dieses traum des lernens nur mit
akustischen input möglich ist
beispielsweise wie man andere studien
hinweise darauf dass beispielsweise
duftstoffe wie rosen dass beim lernen im
schlaf helfen können und auch das
lernen mit musik aber nicht im schlaf
ist ja absolut hilfreich super learning
heißt die technik eine von fünf
methoden die ich im video
die fünf besten methoden zum lernen
vorgestellt habe wenn er ihr drauf liegt
wird es sofort los und wenn ihr zukunft
in zukunft zu diesem und anderen themen
kein video mehr verpassen wollt dann
wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
gemacht hat bleibt dran jetzt nach
reihenfolge